yesterday I came to you with the news
that Alex Jones Infowars website has
filed for chapter 11 bankruptcy
protection and I said Hey listen we've
got to be careful with this because it
seems that it is obviously a way to keep
and hide money from being subject to
settlements because the guys being sued
to high heaven and it's not going well
but it's still interesting he
immediately after the bankruptcy went
public announced an emergency blowout
and I'm not talking about a diaper
blowout caused by all those weird
supplements that he takes I'm I'm
talking about an emergency blowout sale
of these kooky products that he has on
his website so wasting absolutely no
time whatsoever here is Alex Jones big
announcement listen if you've not gotten
drinkable silver this would be a great
opportunity to do it you want us to be
able to stay on air and be able to move
forward in the future I need you you
don't really want that that's the thing
now to not wait
and you go to infowarstore.com
especially those of you that never
bought a book never bought a film never
bought a t-shirt ever got a something
imagine buying a film from Alex Jones
that is something huh well man never got
an air filtration water filtration
shortwave radio thousands of great items
books you name it at infowarstore.com
get your living defense get your
knockout it's back in stock uh bodies
ultimate turmeric formula lung cleanse
the lung cleanse there's a there's a
product I would buy I actually was
thinking to myself what could possibly
be going on in someone's life where you
go to Alex Jones store
to get a lung cleanser I mean like what
if you fall for that you could fall for
anything
they're all there at infowarstore.com
and it's just that simple there's also a
button up on the top of the shopping
cart that says support and it says
become a sponsor and you just click
there and you can give a monthly
donation or just give a one-time
donation and then we actually get 95 of
that money right instead of just you
know 30 or 40 percent 50 with the sale
of the product so
this is Do or Die time if you want to
keep us on air through the the you know
these attacks of the system and the
system pulling out all the stops you
know the crazy thing is like the I've
never met a genuine fan of Alex Jones
I've met people who watch his content
because it's so crazy and they're here
like we do right I mean we kind of keep
an eye on what all of these extremists
do I have never met someone who
seriously watches Alex Jones the
silences then this is the time they are
trying to silence you
they're trying to take down the leading
voice
of resistance if Alex Jones is the
leading voice of resistance we're really
in trouble our good friend Faron cousins
had a good tweet with similar thoughts
to mine from yesterday about the entire
bankruptcy thing a Faron tweeted quote a
lot of people celebrating Alex Jones
filing for bankruptcy but that move just
screws over the victims and allows him
to Shield money from them that they
would otherwise be able to go after this
move protects him and his money
and is not a good thing farron going on
to say the filing also lets him
restructure his business Holdings in
order to keep operating so the hatred
and conspiracies aren't going away so I
don't trust the entire bankruptcy thing
any further than I'd be able to throw
Alex Jones I I don't it just it stinks
to high heaven like I said yesterday and
there are lots of people celebrating it
and I mean listen you can be for speech
but for the failure of certain types of
speech right I mean this and this is
this is like an age-old battle and
debate
um for example I used to interview these
people from the Westboro Baptist Church
and they were the ones who would show up
at soldiers funerals with signs that
would say you know God hates these
people and those people you you know the
people
um I could recognize that they have a
right to speak now you know there are
different laws around and protesting at
funerals and things like that but let's
generally just say I recognize that
people have a right to express their
opinion
but at the same time I can be thrilled
if their opinion is so unsavory that
they sort of like go out of business and
that's kind of what's happened with the
Westboro Baptist Church I'm not saying
that they're bankrupt but they have
become so out of favor where even the
small amount of interest that there was
in their message has evaporated and
they're nowhere now I think that that's
fantastic I'm not against Free Speech
because they're free their speech is
unpopular and similarly there is
absolutely no question whatsoever that
Alex Jones is allowed to have a show
the government shouldn't can't legally I
mean they shouldn't be censoring him
platforms can decide based on their
terms of service whether what Alex Jones
does is or isn't allowed but it's okay
to be happy if Alex Jones particular
speech is so distasteful that it becomes
financially uh inviable not viable that
that's a great thing I'm happy about
that and it's not about oh David do you
do you wish that yeah my Alex Jones
impression right globalished
internationalist Trotsky socialist
unlike Obama trudeoma crown and the rest
of these Zio Bish yeah okay
um I think it's a great thing if his
speech is considered so disgusting that
he can't make money off of it call me
crazy I think that that's a good thing
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
I've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when I use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say I'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up I can delete that virtual
card so I know I'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say I'm
ordering food over the phone but I left
my wallet somewhere I don't have my real
credit card on me I can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is you're not out there
exposing your real credit card number so
you're not as susceptible to data
breaches and identity theft privacy is a
totally free service and you'll get five
bucks to spend when you go to
privacy.com Pacman the link is right
underneath this video